and i think in today's world where again
um covey it's hard to to reach people on
to meet them on conferences and travel
the the ability to to find connections
through personal referral is
way way more important than ever welcome
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm joined by lyron
glickmann global business development
expert and a keynote speaker
leron turned her passion for people
marketing and global travels into a
thriving business as a global business
development expert and international
keynote speaker she is the founder of
the human factor by lyron glickmann a
global business development boutique
firm that helps tech companies grow and
expand to new global markets
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
very good michael i'm so happy to be
here how are you today
good thank you very very much for coming
i look forward to to picking your brain
on on your experience working with
companies as a global business
development consultant and working on on
strategy marketing go to market business
development with various companies
getting insights into what it's like to
break into new markets and and for
meaningful connections in a variety of
case studies that then translate into
you know overarching trends that are
that may be relevant for a lot of other
entrepreneurs that are either you know
in the beginning middle or end of their
journey and so
tell me a little bit about yourself how
do you decide that what you want to do
in the tech scene is to be a
business development consultant and what
does that actually entail
wow so that's uh the million dollar
question it took me a long time to
realize
what and how uh i should do i do uh
basically and in short i started my
career around 20 years ago when i was 16
in a radio local like um national radio
station in israel then moved to the army
spokesperson unit then
israeli tv uh then corporate australia i
mean i had this um
the pathway of studying in media then
starting in marketing for big
corporations uh moved back to israel and
continued to work in sales marketing and
so on it was kind of you know sometimes
relating to tech but not really tech
um and at some point after 12 years of
experience working for different bodies
globally and so on i realized that my
magic powers let's call them it's people
and i actually kind of looked back and
researched and
created this um
and methodology which i'm teaching in
the past 10 years about how to do
business networking how to achieve
results through authentic and strategic
relationships
now at this point around 10 years ago i
i said to myself okay i'm a networker
but
it's not a job so it was kind of hard to
define i knew i'm a networker but i
didn't really didn't really resonate
with
let's give companies you know
services
then i continued you know working in the
taxi and started more working with
startups
for companies giving some types of uh
marketing and business development
services and various startups in them
agritech and sports stack and uh working
with governments and so on and tech
related things
and then i realized that what i've been
doing all the all these years was
business development so
um and and that's kind of how i got to
understand that that's my strength what
i actually do is what you ask is i
actually bring the um services around
the branding go to market and b2b global
business development to companies based
on
all of this experience
and so so what does that actually
intentionally mean when you're working
with a company and you're you know from
the outside coming in and helping them
think through brand through business
development is it usually when they're
when they're struggling and to figure it
out is it either they want to leverage
an outsider's opinion what is really
triggers
a startup to come in and work with the
consultant
yeah so that's a great question um as
for my audience it's usually post seed
rounds where they already have you know
they know what their product is it's
it's ready or almost ready um and
they're about to start either go outside
to the market for pilots looking for
pilots or for clients so at this stage
where i come in the marketing and sales
divisions are not you know figured out
yet
and there are many um i would say
infrastructure um
and things that they need to do it
starts with uh the personal brand of of
you know the founders that have been
happy to share some stories about this
but many times they don't really they
didn't necessarily looked at how they're
being perceived when approaching clients
when approaching investors and that's
one of the most important things because
many of them don't get into the deal
flow of clients or investors and they
don't even know why
and the answer lies in how they're
presenting themselves marketing
themselves then it's about having the
marketing strategy go to market kind of
learning the market and
building the strategy and the actions
they need to take and up to my favorite
things which is door opening really
going into the market start looking for
relevant people to either support them
as board or get them as pilot or clients
so this is kind of the scope that i work
with and of course each company needs
support in different
areas of the ones i mentioned
so i'd love to hear a few case studies
of how you've been working with founders
to to realize that there are these
different trends of well i wouldn't call
them problems but challenges that that
coming from the outside you can help
them overcome
yeah definitely so one of the companies
i worked with uh is actually a company
in the sports innovation space i also
worked in this space uh for for a
different company three years as their
vp partnerships and business
and working with this uh sports company
um we actually wanted to reach to get um
you know to work with different sports
brands now i also had some connections
in this industry while we work together
but um we tried to reach different
sports brands like um adidas or nike or
under our and we realized there were
some
you know struggles to get into the right
person in the company and get him to
listen or possibly work with a with a
startup
so what we decided is to take it from a
different angle we started to look
not for the innovation manager marketing
manager but for what i like to call
the access you know the ex innovation
manager the ex-president the x you know
c-level and it's very it's a very
interesting um
market let's say or segment these access
think about it people who
have done you know their best job is
behind them they have the prestige uh
that the market is you know saving for
them
the relationships the funds and the time
and they still want to stay in the game
sorry so you as a startup beginner with
you know not much of recognition at this
stage when you
harness such people on board you
basically give them sometimes even more
than they can give you in a way because
they're looking to stay in the game
they're looking for this energy for this
thrill in their eyes to to join you so
what we did we actually approached um
ex-president of reebok for example and
different of those x's and and got them
to be on the board of the company and
once they were on the board they were
able to to open doors for us and you
know help us get into the market so this
is a great example of what companies can
do and don't always think about but when
they reach these you know functions
these people
really there are many many doors that
would have never been opened are just
available for them
and so
you know why why do you think it's more
difficult for founders or for people
that are interactively working on the
home to
to not see it for example this really
creative idea and this is not something
that i would think about myself this
idea of approaching the x
position uh or the the person who's
holding the previous position or the
role in this company
yeah well that's an interesting question
i can only answer of course from my
experience but um another client of mine
for example um a great company in the
sporting dancer in the sales um teams
motivation space brilliant people three
founders each of them you know have
great credentials and the ceo is
actually a full-time entrepreneur he
sold two of his former companies
and you know when i started working with
them and i got this information from him
and i looked at their you know marketing
materials and how they present
themselves and calls with clients and
investors he never mentioned that that
nevertheless he didn't even want to
mention that when i told him why aren't
you presenting this so and when i got on
board i made sure that this will you
know this important data will be
conveyed in the right and intelligent
way through conversations through the
marketing materials and you know image
and it's very important it will open the
door i call it like a supporter
um so i think um to your question to
answer your question sometimes you know
they're much involved in the r d and the
development in getting the product right
and if they don't have a marketing
strength as part of their skills they
may not see um
small details that maybe for us
marketers it looks pretty trivial but
for them maybe it's it's not you know in
their on the radar tell me a little bit
about branding and what you've learned
from working with companies on on their
own branding
so branding is a wide you know um it's a
wide topic it's very important there are
you know countries branding cities
branding startups brandings and people's
branding i um more focus on the people
brand um
i think it's you know it's correlates
and in a very strong way to to
networking and essentially as a as a
founder as um even salesperson in the
company
you you should know how to network and
how to create the right relationships so
your brand has its importance that you
will be aware of that
um and i'll tell you i'll tell you a
quick story um which happened to to me i
was representing one of the companies i
work with um in new york they sent me to
new york and i met with an investor not
for getting an investment it was merely
for getting his um you know connections
and and you know advice
i gave him the pitch for the company and
he's told me
he was quiet and then he said you know
i'm sorry but i think this company is
fiction
and i'm like okay well if such a person
an investor i met him in the world trade
center you know very high level person
said that then they're probably a very
uh important lesson i can learn so i
said okay please explain
and he said you know our analysts looked
at the company and they saw that the
information you just told me doesn't
relates to what the deck says what one
thunder has on his um linkedin the year
he started is different than the year
the other founder started he started to
giving me to give me you know this
checklist of what we did wrong in our
branding and messaging and all i could
do michael would say thank you thank you
so much because companies don't get into
the deal flow and they don't even know
why so when we talk about branding how
founders and the team members especially
if it's a small company brand their
cells what they decided to emphasize as
the credibility
drivers
where the people they associate with or
bring to the company or so on has
immense immense um importance especially
today when we don't meet people
face-to-face so
what we found when we google ourselves
is way important and if you or listeners
haven't googled yourself lately i
definitely recommend you do that and i
hope you'll be surprised for the best
but if not there's always what to do
about it
so i guess the important lesson to be
learned here is the importance of not
just branding the company what it does
but especially in the earlier stages the
the br not just the branding of the
people behind the company but also the
consistency and and making sure that
it's the right messaging that is
appropriate for for what the company is
actually trying to achieve right
exactly and i liked what you said about
consistency um because you know and i
see it a lot with the companies i work
with as company grow you know it reach
the different milestones every month two
months or a certain amount of time
things change if it's the amount of
users the
you know many many information and it's
important to kind of go back to
marketing materials and again maybe your
verbal pitch and really make the small
tweaks small updates that now we have
six thousand users and no not four
thousand users for example so keep the
consistency but also adjust it as you
grow and
and change
so we talked about branding we talked
about go to markets talk to me a little
bit about marketing and specifically in
the in here you know it requires your
understanding of not just what the
product does it requires your
understanding of of who the market is
for the for the company and how to and
what is the right way to to approach
them
what is sort of the process that you
bring with you as you work with
companies on their own marketing
strategies
yeah well basically you know when you
get into a new market and i would say
working mainly with israeli companies uh
our main market is the u.s sometimes
europe um the process is you know is the
basic is kind of understand the market
research the market find the right um
you know if it's competitors or so on
and do all the analysis that most of us
know so i don't want to kind of you know
repeat that but what i uh emphasize uh
put more emphasize on is really about
the
the people that we want to approach and
that's even drive us from the you know
go to market to the builder
so kind of find who are the not only the
people that um essentially we want them
to see our
our marketing efforts for example if
you're an investor i may connect you and
connect with you on linkedin and make
sure that you will be able to see the
the post i do i i put online and so on i
want you to get exposed to my marketing
efforts but i also want to see how i you
know
get not only the clients that i want but
also surround myself with uh stake with
maybe board members or advisors or
people that um i can get their help into
understanding the market better into
getting um
uh referrals
and i think in today's world where again
um covey it's hard to to reach people on
to meet them on conferences and travel
the the ability to to find connections
through personal referral is
way way more important than ever and i
found different uh with my with my
clients we found different types of um
channels you know to to reach those
people
right and so
do you usually find as you're working on
these three verticals with
founders specifically do you how do you
find your relationship works
you as the consultant them as the
founders what what is the give and take
and how long are these usual you know
how long do you usually work with them
is it is it ongoing throughout the
lifetime of the company is it for a set
period of time for a specific issue
yeah so most of the companies that
approach me
are usually for for the long term i mean
we are you know i'm with them until
they have a big um until i mean they
grow and develop their own marketing or
business development uh department
um i can also say you know unfortunately
covered also you know caused um one of
them to kind of you know change the
course but that's part of what's
happened these days
um and basically the relationship is it
depends i mean some companies i'm
everyone all of my companies i meet them
once a week i'm very much involved so
you know on paper i'm with them we meet
once a week i understand their struggles
and i give them
we think together about strategic ways
to tackle them i'm also in touch with
the team and so on but but out of paper
i'm very much involved i mean for me you
know as a consultant i really have the i
would say the privilege to also um
choose who i want to work with as much
as they choose me and i usually i work
from the heart so i'm usually very much
involved you know i'm in touch with them
on a personal level on a business level
right i talk to the team so it's not
only about you know the marketing and
business it's more about understanding
and i believe in that you know
eventually it's about people so it's
really understanding the people the team
what drives them how can i make help
them make more and grow uh from what
they're doing for you know until they're
fulfilling themselves and pushing
themselves as far as i are
take me concerned a little bit to your
childhood and i want to understand you
better what what really fascinated you
as a kid growing up
so we talked about it just a few minutes
before uh you know we started this
interview and
i think what fascinated me and still
today is people
you know i was always if i'm trying to
you know to remember them people with
unique stories uh like uh oprah winfrey
or um
i remember uri geller you know as a
magician that does you know things that
are kind of impossible so i was always
attracted to these people that have done
the impossible and kind of you know
against all odds you know believe that
anything is possible and did it
amazing and and if you look today what
really inspires you and your day-to-day
as you as you either work with founders
as you as you think about you know the
different companies that you will choose
to work with
um the answer again is is people um you
know i like um i'm inspired by people
that really um are very committed to
their goal people that you see in their
eyes that they're passionate and they're
able and they're willing to do what it
takes uh to fulfill their goals um
you know i'm inspired from a lot of
little things if you know if i see
someone here donates for something or do
good things i'm just you know inspired
by good deeds and people that following
their dreams and i think you know it
comes from
my house being a daughter of uh
of a pilot my father has an unusual path
to achieving uh to becoming a commercial
partner and he always fulfilled his
dream so i guess it was kind of embedded
in me also to be
follow my dream be passionate and i like
that in other people as well
and so as you as you consider different
opportunities for different companies to
work with and you mentioned that you're
working very closely with them how do
you
how do you try to ensure that you know
there is the right match on a personal
level that these are the types of people
that will continue inspiring you
yeah well first of all you know as a
consultant the responsibility is on me
you know if they choose to work with me
then my responsibility is to make sure
that they get as much from working with
me so uh you know first of all there
should be a personal connection but also
then it's on my shoulder i think about
them you know when i go to sleep when i
wake up um i always try to think what i
can do better for them uh you know as a
service provider approach um
but i guess you know like anything first
of all it's about chemistry with people
it's about understanding that their
goals is something that aligns with what
i can provide
uh if their field is the field that i'm
you know feel comfortable to support in
them
but it's also about the you know the
product um their solution
so it's true it's usually you know um a
few ways first of all like the personal
their goals the product
and then it's you know if it's a magic
so much
i love it and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
so you know it's kind of embarrassing to
say
but
if i am if i would uh describe myself
then i would say that i'm a people
person something that has always been
embedded in me
um i'm a very passionate person i like
to work with passion to surround myself
with people with passion and i'm very
very extremely positive
thank you very very much this is
wonderful and thank you for the great
work that you're doing and the founders
that you're helping and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
thank you for having me michael and
thank you for being with us
[Music]